[Music]
have you changed your mind about
anything recently any ideas or policies
I think over the whole of a lifetime
I've been in public life for 50 years
now I've changed my mind as facts and
the world around me has changed but I've
I hope that I've been able to stick to
the fundamental values that I espoused
when I was in my early 20s and I still a
dear to now of equality and justice of
above all people being able to have a
say in their own lives to be able to
come together for mutuality and
reciprocity so that they in their own
terms can counterweight the power of
those who exercise influence across the
world but actually can feel some
satisfaction that they made a difference
not just to themselves but to people
around them how do your your values that
you hold so dear how how are they
implemented by the current government
what do you think about what labor is
trying to do and what the Conservatives
are doing and how they're affecting that
I think it's universally accepted
whatever one's politics that we are in a
terrible mess politically as a country
that the divisions that were created
over the referendum three years ago
rests very heavily with us that those
divisions need to be healed but not
simply by trying to fudge our way
forward but to try to identify what
unites people the big challenges of the
future that we can rally round and work
together on and I hope that my own party
the Labour Party will appreciate from
the leader downwards that to be able to
make a difference to be able to change
the world we've got to be able to win
people over to want to supporters and
whether you believe in very radical left
policies or not those policies have got
to be in tune with the wishes of the
people and I hope when we have a new
prime minister that there will in short
order be a general election and that
will be able to express that but at the
moment the biggest challenge of all is
to try and
sort out what's going to happen with
Britain's role in the European Union and
as a consequence Britain's role in the
world so you've talked about
communication versus action in your
interview with Philip a bit earlier and
you're touching upon this now as well
and he was asking whether you know in
which we're missing something about him
speaking to people's emotions and
obviously Nigel Faraj is someone who's
very good at speaking to people's
emotions why do you think he's so
successful at it and what do you think
labour should do to address that more I
think historically those who have been
able to what's now called used the
populist forum have appealed to very
basic instincts in people and they've
been able to translate those instincts
into very simple political messages and
that was undertaken by Donald Trump in
winning the presidential election it's
the kind of attitude that Nigel Farage
is adopted and not just recently but
throughout his political life and what
it says is you should be against the
establishment you should be against
those who are the the ruling class
whilst he himself is actually part of it
and has been as a broker in the
financial markets and it's a strange
paradox that Nigel crush so saw no
contradiction in marrying a German and
then campaigning to get Britain out of
Europe and being partners with and
combining the power that we should have
with Germany France Spain and the other
European nations so we're in a very
contradictory put place at the moment
where people are being appealed to for
things that actually are not in their
best interests but it's being presented
cleverly as though they are and I think
from a social democratic point of view
we've got to reconnect we've got to use
the language that people understand but
and to to not simplify the solutions
because they're not simple sort of
but to put it in a way that people can
understand and then give them real hope
for the future because I think at the
moment people are so down there's so
much feeling of disillusionment a misery
that what we need to do is to provide
the optimism and hope for the future and
do you have them so one of the questions
we've asked people was who do who do
they want to become the leader of the UK
and then who did they think will become
the next leader of the UK now that
tourism is stepping down well of course
I mean I've been a member of the Labour
Party for 55 years so I'd want the Prime
Minister to be from the Labour Party but
of course that isn't going to happen in
the short term because the campaign will
begin when it's already begun but it
will begin in earnest from the 10th of
June over the following six weeks the
Conservatives will elect their leader
their leader presuming that they can get
a vote of confidence through the House
of Commons will present themselves to
Her Majesty the Queen they will then be
designated and inaugurated as prime
minister and then we have two major
challenges one is of course the issue of
Britain's relationship with Europe and
whether we are coming out of the
European Union under what terms and the
second is what kind of policies and
strategy and vision for the future that
conservative-led government without a
majority will put forward and on that
label will then not only have to respond
but to put its alternative policies
strategy and vision of the future so
would it be Jeremy Corbyn that you would
want to be handled
well if I was faced with persuading
people as to whether they should vote
for someone like Boris Johnson or
whether they should vote for a Labour
Party with Jamie Lee Jeremy Corbyn as
its leader I would obviously want people
to vote Labour I want people to get a
prime minister that believes in the
values of equality and justice and I'd
want the leader the Labour leader to
understand the importance of reaching
out of being able to hear what people
have got to say and to combine the
strength of the British nation behind
those values but with policies that
unite rather than divide the United
Kingdom one of the controversies around
her is amazed and bracketed deal and had
to do with them the island Baxter and
you you've obviously worked on the Good
Friday Agreement and I was wondering
what you thought about about this and as
you were reading about it well the most
extraordinary thing of Theresa Mays
three years in the Premiership was that
she didn't go immediately to the
Republic of Ireland to talk to their tea
shop the prime minister to negotiate a
way forward that they could then have
jointly put to the remainder of the
European Union because the real European
Union will back the Republic of Ireland
why wouldn't they the Republic Island is
a member of the European Union and
intends to stay member so that's the
first thing that any incoming Prime
Minister needs to understand you've got
to get agreement with the Irish
government themselves secondly you've
then got to be able to translate that
into persuading sufficient people within
the House of Commons again without a
majority for any single party to back
that along with whatever tweaking and
changes in the deal can be reached or
you've got to put it back to the British
people
and as a former Home Secretary what did
you make of the recent kind of migration
related scandals it is the wind rush or
amber rods initiative of like making
companies disclose the nationality of
their employees and the foreign students
English competency test deputations
and the list can go on yes I think that
one of the things to resume will not
want to be remembered for in our time as
Home Secretary was the message that she
sent out through the civil service and
beyond and that was the hostile
environment because that it did
absolutely nothing to make sure we had
an ordered control of our borders and
sensible migration and Refugee programs
but he did everything to create a
attention and division within the
country which frankly was very dangerous
and if you look back at your amazing
career in in politics and how do you see
Tony Blair's leadership now when you
think about it retrospectively and what
do you think about it
in economically as well people only left
and center-left tend to refer all the
time to the decision to join the United
States in invading Iraq and removing
Saddam Hussein I think Tony Blair's 10
years in Premiership will be remembered
for the incredibly benign economic
picture that the government oversaw with
lower employment low interest rates high
public spending a unified country that
felt at ease with itself and I think
that will be the legacy that I hope will
be the mantle if you like of Tony
Blair's 10 years and I was very proud to
be a member of the cabinet during the
the eight years that I served from 97 to
the end of 2005 and
in terms of privatization versus
nationalization where do you stand now I
think we need a mixed economy where we
have partnership between the public and
private sector where there are areas of
our economy where it's sensible for us
to own those assets whether it's the
railways or even the the water company
the natural resource that we take for
granted I would want us to do so in a
way that wasn't dogmatic wasn't simply
about taking things away from other
people but about uniting around giving
people a real say in how their services
are run how the products are delivered
and above all how we deal with the
challenges of robotics and artificial
intelligence how we deal with the
challenges of an aging population and
how we join with others on counter
weighting countervailing the power of
International Finance of the tech
companies of the growing power of other
nations like China and India how can we
do that in a civilized way in a world
that will be pulling together in the
interests of overcoming poverty and
disadvantage rather than creating
division and a feeling that
nation-states should simply look after
themselves rather than understanding how
independent and independent they are in
a world of rapid climate change of
massive changes in communication
technology and in the world of work and
if we can start to address how we
combine to deal with those issues then I
think we will reach people in a way that
turns them away from right-wing populism
unpleasant and exclusive nationalism and
instead gets people to understand that
mutuality and reciprocity of working
together is the only way we can create a
civilized future for our children and
grandchildren so how how do you hope
this communication could
happen is it through national assembly's
like I learned hell and and France have
tried recently or is it a matter of
because you were saying that the people
must have a say in it as well so I was
wondering how you need to start from the
bottom what people need to feel that
they're having a say in their
neighborhood and community in their
local government area in a much more
progressive and ambitious way we've
tried citizens assemblies here the
University of Sheffield and the
University of Southampton I took part in
these of undertaking experiments they
need to be carried through in a much
more thorough and long-lasting way so we
don't just have an experiment and then
it it goes away and I'd like to see
government investing in programs of that
sort not just to test the water and see
what people think but to give them a
real say in how to do it because if it
in every public service in every
industry you'll find people who have a
very clear vision of what needs to be
changed and improved for the future and
their voices are so often squeezed out
listen to people where there are
citizens or as employees or as consumers
and then look at mechanisms for making
that voice heard thank you very much
indeed thank you thank you for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you